las autoridades marítimas británicas y
francesas faltaron a su deber de
proteger individuos en peligro para la
asociación utopía 56 no hay duda los
defensores de los derechos humanos
presentaron una denuncia contra la
prefectura marítima de la moncha y dos
individuos más cerca de un mes después
del naufragio de una embarcación frente
a costa de cali donde 27 personas en
mayoría kurdos iraquíes fallecieron dijo
lipsic los migrantes refugiados
exiliados intentaron llamar los
servicios de emergencia británicos y
franceses mientras su embarcación se
estaba hundiendo estos servicios se
lavaron las manos nos ocurrieron a la
gente que estaba en apuros es a partir
de este momento que nos planteamos la
responsabilidad penal de arquitectos de
tres una investigación está en proceso
pero sólo en el lado francés y según el
periódico lo mont los primeros elementos
demuestran que si hubo llamadas a los
servicios de emergencia gracias a las
facturas telefónicas detalladas que
obtuvo la policía los dos únicos
rescatados del desastre confiaron a un
medio kurdo que llamaron por ayuda tan
pronto el motor del bote se averió
finalmente fue un buque de pesca francés
que dio la alerta pero demasiado tarde
para evitar la tragedia
lo que sorprende es el tiempo infinito
que pasó ya que pudieron ser detectados
si me permite decirlo gracias a este
navío de pesca a las 2 de la tarde y que
es en este momento que la llamada de
auxilio fue registrada oficialmente ojos
y su oficina la prefectura marítima
afirma por su lado que no tuvo
conocimiento de la situación para
iniciar un rescate a tiempo